très belle image que je garde de toi que
j'ai lu un jour dans un journal c'est un
blockhaus on voir l'atlantique
est interdite blockhaus et des bougies
il ya deux versions qui écoute du jazz
c'est toi et au niveau des stacks
exactement beau ça non je sais pas je
vois très bien la scène et comment qui
commente une vache est passé à l'article
j'avais lu sur toi dans un journal et
c'est une image qui m'a toujours un
millier d ce pack c'était un véritable
génie de la guitare d'un garçon si vous
l'avez pas retirer la vie
c'est à mon sens doute aujourd'hui un
des plus grands musiciens de jazz
guitariste qui soir il a joué du reste
avec les plus grands des sceaux de
l'époque c'était un enfant prodige tout
a commencé sacha n'est pas en faisant
des concours le petit chanteur tout
chanté en avril à paris comme ça c'était
quoi en avril à paris ça faisait que
c'était une chanson de charles trenet
qui faisaient quand paris avait rayon
bras de saleh d'exil de shoot à chanter
ça il y avait traîné quitter la syrie
alors entraînée m'a dit vous savez vous
devriez en faire un dix parce que vous
l'a chanté beaucoup mieux que moi et
alors parallèlement à ta carrière de
compositeur tu es mené une carrière de
chanteur donc les gens 66 pour la
première fois tu as décidé d'arrêter
puisque très marrant si tous les dijon
66 ans 76 ans 86 tous décident d'arrêter
en 66 kg dimanche le chanteur son public
je patinais comme charles dumont un
champ du nord du mans
non charles dumont contraire il a mis là
il a eu du mal à accrocher mais une fois
qu'il a marché il va bien 76 pareil tu
fais un concert au palais des congrès
puis tu t'aperçois que les gens écoutent
pas tellement ce que tu chantes cette
foulée voulais tu t'arrêtes ans le
pratiquement plein milieu du cancer non
bouillie parce que là j'ai vraiment
content là j'ai compris que c'est
compliqué que ma carrière le chanteur se
charles avait terminé pourquoi tu penses
bien parce que je pense que je ne suis
pas quelqu'un qui est fait pour chanter
tout seul sur une scène d'abord parce
que si je ne suis pas en confiance
ouais
si quelqu'un qui est très traquer non et
je pense que je ne me sentais bien en
petit comité ou alors digestive dans un
contexte malgré des copains dure deux
mois
disons une épaule et
et murray percute alors un bundle des
vibrations une chaleur chose mais alors
dix ans plus tard en 86 tech encore fait
une chanson
cela dit si de bouche en tpu c'est parce
qu'il y avait des problèmes dentaires en
fait il voulait toujours chanter ce que
maman est là non j'avais envie de
chanter j'ai fait ou chantons les
souvenirs oui je les suis dit que six
ans plus tard ça ça va être un nombre un
tireur non seulement ça n'a pas été un
tube était vide total même si ses
chansons des plus grands compositeurs ne
se sont mis à chanter et d'arriver tous
les dix ans pourquoi 96 tu vas arrêter
encore oui alors pour chantal tu as
inventé
le music hall pour enfants quoi
n'hésitez pas j'avais envie vraiment de
faire un très grand spectacle comme le
châtelet en effet autrefois un peu dans
la tradition du monde en 80 jours est au
tour du monde en 80 jours
et moi j'ai voulu la montée aux frères
une sorte que j'avais dans ma tête
depuis depuis tous bords
ce que ma mère m'emmenait au s'appelait
voir luis mariano d'un certain qu'un
succès fou oui la nouille à magnas
existe oui ça existe ça nous a rapporté
beaucoup d'argent
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent gilles côté
j'espère n'ont pas vraiment je mentirais
si je ne dis pas que j'ai qu'on a gagné
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent mais c'est
pas du tout ce qu'on a cherché je sais
qu'on était très critiqué sur ce temps
là mais qu'on ne savait pas c'est qu'on
avait 110 personnes à l'année entre la
technique les techniciens les arte elle
avait quand même la responsabilité de
110 personnes et la dernière tournée
a été
assez kadhafi
à cause d'une certaine émission alors
juste voir à présent disponibles onze
ans et bien c'est passé à cause de cette
tournée je
on a pratiquement on a perdu tout ce
qu'on avait gagné
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement moi
je résume à bram 3 ans la vie continue
et puis et puis l'argent bah c'est pas
tout mais j'ai vu l'émission lambert
c'était bien parti au début puis d'un
seul coup et s'est énervé comme ça elle
a commencé à s'auto carrick actions de
la société a surtout bien sûr tout
détruire les lycées passé oui il s'est
passé une chose est claire c'est
l'alcool sinon pas l'alcool j'entends ne
voit pas c'est quoi alors je ne sais pas
ce qui s'est passé une chose c'est
qu'elle était depuis trois semaines en
tournée ouais elle jouait deux
spectacles par l'humour est et quand
elle est arrivée à lyon c'était très
fatigué et
elle m'a dit est ce que tu chériras
est-ce que tu iras dans la régie pour
entendu question est posée et là où où
monsieur ni grain bac était très
malhonnête rester qsi sabatier qui n'en
est pas à son premier coup d'envoi -
interdit l'entrée dans la régie ah bon
carrément ils m'ont fait enfermer
normalement j'aurais été dans le cas
puisqu'on est à la fois les questions
étaient blancs dira rien changé à
sochaux la seule chose que je vais vous
dire aujourd'hui qui est vrai c'est que
la fameuse maîtresse d'école qui
insultent et chantal en lui disant
d'être ridicule avec appétit pian vous
êtes lamentables vous ètes ça et bien
cette maîtresse d'école est fausse elle
n'existe pas parce que moi j'ai fait une
recherche effet cette même famille qui a
qui a servi aussi pour un militaire
enfin pour poser des questions
très vicieuse à rika zaraï et comme
c'est la règle j'ai retenu la même voie
car maîtresse d'école
et puis dans le village comme chantal
lundi mais nous est hôtesse décolle donc
un village elle lui a dit a rebondi vous
êtes vous êtes vous diriger une école de
quelle année de quel âge
oui elle lui a pas répondu et si ç'avait
été une vraie maîtresse d'école
elle lui aurait dit j'ai je dirige une
école de saint etienne 2 8e ou 9e est
d'accord donc clidat cas si l'on prend
jeudi ils t'ont pas laisser rompre
quittons pas les séries moi j'ai
financiers et à bondy c'est justement un
maître d'école qui acquit acquis via
l'école
le style graphique 2001 donc je peux
vous dire que cette émission était
truquée et qu'il y avait des gens tout
était pape badiane y avait des gens qui
appelaient vraiment mais je peux vous
dire que ce jour là franchement c'est
pas je peux vous dire que
de toute manière sa batterie ou les
frasques ou qu'il attendait chantal au
tournant parce qu'il savait que vous
savez que quand on a du succès et quand
le succès dure vous savez qu'il ya
toujours des gens qui savent et rendrait
bon mais ça c'est pas simplement en
france existe aussi en amérique ça
existe en allemagne ça existe dans tous
les pays du monde
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi la
probable c'est pas du mali s'est passé
qui ne l'a pas plus haute volée parce
que d'une part et c'est très très
fatiguée elle était grippé 40 de fièvre
avant de fermer les styles mais bon elle
avait pris 10 5 nuls
pour couper la fièvre et toux et j'ai
trouvé que ne pas priver tous ces
enfants cité devant elle dans la femme
et qui lui réclamait des chansons et qui
comprenait pas bien ce qui se passerait
parce qu'elles font jour il faut aussi
savoir que ce juge ma vérité tout s'est
fait dans une phase de spectacle
on était en robe de scène olivier des
artistes ils accompagnent oui alors que
les autres jeux de la vérité c'était
dans un studio au beach ou aux buttes
chaumont
je n'ai pas les prendre pendant leur
spectacle est tout de suite après avoir
donné leur spectacle c'était après
spect'art et wiba qu'elle avait joué
l'après midi et après sa carrière s'en
est ressentie quand même oui sa carrière
son ressenti puisque la tournée s'est
arrêtée et il mais il a tourné à et il
se trouve que bien justement on parlait
de l'argent qu'on a gagné tout à l'heure
du conte à gagner de l'argent mais je
peux vous dire que tout ce qu'on avait
gagné on l'a perdue dans ses tournées et
à cause de cette émission c'est un
artiste épouvantable et paru dans le
figaro magazine où
chantal avait donné rendez-vous
apparemment un photographe les enfants
étaient dehors dans le froid enfin quand
on lit l'article c'est terrible et
enfants étaient dehors dans le froid
ensuite chantal arrive on fait les
photos le soir au restaurant le reporter
dit qu'on pratiquement et connexes à
celui qui paye la note pour les 14
personnes
il fallait qu'ils payent les danseuses
c'est quoi ce qui sera bon alors cette
histoire je voulais je vais vous dire ce
que fait c'est un règlement de comptes
purement et simplement qu'ils étaient
exercées par monsieur hervé de talhouët
3 nous dont la santé conseillère
municipale et à l'habitat 6 km de saint
loup sur thouet il était membre de la
famille qui devait hériter de ce château
à l'accord il a profité de sa pause de
sa position figaro magazine pour nous
assassiner et comme on dit vulgairement
temps nous flinguer parce que monsieur
de talhouët 3 n'a pas supporté que des
gens de music hall le spectacle l'achète
le château de ta g par jour
c'est quand il était l'héritier avec son
cousin qui
et ça il n'a il m'a il a tout inventé
c'est très méchant mais c'est quand même
très étrange que ce monsieur a vite à 6
km et que dans sa famille il ya aussi
des gens qui ont un château qui font un
spectacle pas très loin et ça c'est
quand même très malhonnête de satan et
très malhonnête aussi du journal qui a
laissé faire cet article
oui rassurez vous je fais un bon
spectacle cet été
messieurs de talent et 3 ne s'en sortira
pas gagnant de cette histoire bien que
je lui souhaite aucun mal simplement je
peux lui dire publiquement je peux lui
dire que qu'il a fait quelque chose de
très moss et de répugnante
- coup de champagne sans gaz carbonique
c'est pour ça que tu mets des glaces
gens parce que quand on est du glaçon
dans le vrai ça tu le gardes terrebonne
mais voilà et c'est ce qui fait que le
lendemain on n'a pas trente voix la
pratique on revient vendredi ou quoi oui